hey man it's me Kevin Smith I'm gonna
show you this little video I shot I was
watching the flash what you haven't seen
it watch it's amazing the show got to
the season finale and for some reason I
don't even know why nobody told me to or
anything but as we got to what I knew
was the big climax building tour the
whole season very racing back through
time to hopefully save his mom I had the
foresight to set up a camera as we do in
the 21st century it doesn't happen
unless somebody else sees it if it
happens and brought to us by ourselves
that didn't happen
tree fall on the woods [ __ ] that so I
put a camera up and I shot me watching
the last act of the flash season finale
from season one and it's kind of it's
well I don't even go say watch this fat
man blubber at a man in a red suit ain't
even Santa it's crazy how emotional this
Kevin Smith gets so without further ado
let's kick back and watch Kevin Smith
reacts to the flash season finale pull
out your tissues cuz you're gonna be
crying too from laughing at how much I'm
like I get that real sad cry thing going
on check it out
huh this is the speedforce
group past present your future
to focus on where you want to go
I
ejected hydrogen particle
what's that what happened was Barry he's
gone look normal
it is stable start the clock
I don't
you look just like my father
make any sense
but it's me
Oh who's there
taken back
tired I'm okay flogged
well there it is my credibility is
ruined across every medium now not just
in films and TV but here on the internet
they like you cry you cry like a [ __ ]
at the flesh I do cuz I show is that
good man do me a favor you want to see
me cry at more things subscribe more
people join up I'll just start watching
stuff and bawling about it man it'll
become like the Claire Danes channel you
ever watch homeland just cries at
everything that's what I'm gonna do she
won an Emmy so I'm gonna try to win an
Emmy I'm gonna be it's beautiful man so
anyway subscribe see you later